[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's
facts 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor hello friends this
is pastor jean ross pastor doug is out
this evening but how about an amazing
fact
at the entrance to the gray fires
cemetery in edinburgh scotland is a
statue of a sky terrier named bobby
this little terrier was a familiar sight
in the 1850s as he trotted beside his
master policeman alt jock on their
nightly rounds
then in 1858 his master jock suddenly
died of tuberculosis and was buried in
the grey friar's cemetery
much to the surprise of the residents of
edinburgh
a bobby refused to leave jock's grave
cemetery workers repeatedly shooed him
away but he kept returning to the spot
where his master was buried
stormy weather freezing nights the
ground keepers well-meaning locals and
even jock's family all tried to entice
him away from his self-appointed post
but without success
month after month and year after year he
sat guarding his master's grave
bobby would only leave his post for a
few minutes at one o'clock in the
afternoon following the firing of the
cannon in edinburgh's castle he would
cross the cobblestone street to a pub
where he was fed table scraps and then
returned to his faithful watch
crowds came to the cemetery just to see
this amazing dog
for 14 years he kept watch at his
master's grave until he died on the 14th
of january 1872
at the age of 16
a long life for a sky terrier
he was duly buried next to his master
and these words were written on his
grave marker
grey friar's bobby let his loyalty and
devotion be a lesson to us all
well you know friends bobby's
faithfulness to his earthly master
is a reminder to us to be faithful to
our heavenly master jesus
the bible speaks of god's people in the
last days needing to have
endurance
we want to welcome all of those who are
joining us to bible answers live this is
a live interactive international bible
study so if you have a bible related
question we would love to hear from you
this evening the phone number to call
with your bible question is 800-463-7297
and that will get you on the air and
we'll be happy to hear from you this
evening and joining me is pastor carlos
munoz who is helping with the phones
pastor carlos welcome to bible answers
live
i'm glad you're here it's a pleasure to
be here okay
well we started the uh program by
talking about a little dog who is uh was
proven to be very faithful to his master
i've actually been to scotland to
edinburgh and we've driven past the
cemetery and sure enough there's this
little statue of the dog known as bobby
bobby the faithful watchdog apparently
he would growl at people if they came
too close to his master's grave but for
14 years he said god talk about
faithfulness
now of course pets mean a lot to us and
i'm sure you probably have a faithful
pet maybe growing up did you have a dog
growing up yeah i had a few not as
faithful as bobby though and not as
faithful as bobby you know uh i
read this one
a prayer that was actually prayed by a
pet owner it said lord let me become the
person my dog already thinks i am amen
you know dogs do have a faithfulness
that that really is an illustration of
of what we need to have we need to be
faithful christians i'm reminded of
something that jesus said we find this
in matthew 24
speaking of end time events jesus said
for nation will rise against nation and
kingdom against kingdom
there'll be famines and pestilences well
of course we know that's true today and
earthquakes in various places i
understand carlos there was just an
earthquake yesterday
in haiti
and verse 8 matthew 24 verse 8 and there
this is the beginning of sorrows jesus
said and they will deliver you up to
tribute to uh and you will be livid up
to tribulation and kill you and you will
be hated by all nations for my name's
sake
and verse 10 says and then many will be
offended and will betray one another and
will hate one another many false
prophets will arise and deceive many and
because lawlessness will abound
the love of many will grow cold but
here's the point i want to emphasize
verse 13 but he that endures to the end
jesus said
will be saved to be a christian in these
last days requires endurance and
perseverance
i'm also reminded of another verse that
we find in revelation chapter 14 verse
talking about the remnant those who are
living at the end of time and it says
here is the patience of the saints here
are those who keep the commandments of
god and have the faith of jesus
so god's people in the last days will
have loyalty they will have endurance
and perseverance now we do have a free
offer that talks about the importance of
perseverance and being faithful in the
christian life it is a book written by
pastor doug batchelor it's entitled
assurance justification made simple how
can we have that perseverance well we
need to accept everything that jesus has
done for us and everything jesus wants
to do in us and through us and our free
book it's all about that and we'd be
happy to send that to anyone in north
america who would call and ask so pastor
carlos
who does a person call if they want to
get the book
if they want to get the book they have
to call 1-800-835-6747
for the free offer and again just ask
for the book written by pastor doug it's
called assurance
justification made simple and once again
if you have a bible related question the
number to call hearing to the studio is
800-463-7297
if you don't get in right away just stay
on the phone i'm sure one of our our
call screeners will be able to take your
call so again that number is 800 463
and pastor carlos do we have anyone
waiting online at the moment we have a
number of people waiting uh before we do
that let's have a word of prayer thank
you
father we thank you again for the
blessing and the opportunity to come
together and spend time in your word
with the callers
so that we can grow the faith to
persevere until the end too and so as we
go
collaborate and uh spend time we just
ask that your spirit guide us and we ask
us in jesus name amen amen yes so we
have our first caller
is greg calling us from michigan greg
good evening you're on the air
hi pastor john and carlos
my question is
what empirical evidence exists to firmly
establish the date of the stoning of
stephen at 34 a.d i know it fits
perfectly into
the prophecy of daniel but i've seen
conflicting dates on the internet of 34
and 36.
okay well that's a good question i think
part of the confusion that some people
might have is because of the adbc dating
method and of course people know that bc
stands for before christ and then 80 at
o domini it's actually latin it means in
the euro of our lord
and the adbc dating system was not
actually established until a number of
years after christ so several actually i
think
100 200 years after christ
maybe even a little later they began to
date things that way and they kind of
went back
they weren't exactly accurate with the
date of christ's birth jesus was
actually born somewhere around
4 bc
so then that would make his baptism 27
his death 31 a.d and then the stoning of
stephen would be 3480. now the reason we
know 34 a.d is a solid date is because
we know the baptism of jesus we know
that's a solid date we also know that
christ ministered for three and a half
years in person and then he was
crucified of course he rose from the
dead and then you have another three and
a half years when the apostles primarily
focus their missionary activity on the
jews
and then the stoning of stephen
was sort of the end of that three and a
half time period committed to
reaching the jews
of course saul is converted that same
year and he becomes paul the apostle to
the gentiles
and so we know that was sort of the
close of that probationary time period
that god had given to the jews to come
to repentance
so that's probably part of the confusion
why you see different dates but
you know if you look at a good
commentary
it'll make it quite clear that 4 bc was
right around 4 or 3 bc is the birth of
jesus his baptism is 27 he's death 31
stoning of stephen 34.
all right i understand uh you know
you know before bc and all that
the question i have is
what what establishes for sure that
stoning esteem was
was uh 34 and not 36 do we have other
historical evidence to correspond with
it okay well we got internal evidence
from the bible that gives us the year
when um christ was born
where we have the decree by caesar
augustus
that all the world should be taxed and
that of course brought joseph and mary
to bethlehem
uh the bible says you know sees augustus
made that decree and we also know from
outside biblical accounts that that
decree did go into effect by caesar
augustus in 4 bc or there about 4 bc or
3 bc so that's the external evidence
that once you got that date
then of course you just simply do the
math and follow it through
jesus was 30 at his baptism
he died three and a half years later
stephen was done three and a half years
after that
okay
all right well thanks for your call good
question i appreciate it all right next
question we have anthony from my home
state of new york anthony good evening
you're on the air
good evening pastors thank you for
taking my call you're welcome um
my question is
what commandment or which commandment
did adam and eve break
um i was thinking is it also not coveted
is it also not having no other gods
before me because they want it to be
like god
okay i think it was more than one
so let's just kind of go through the
list so it begins with uh you know we
have eve looking at the tree and it says
that she saw the tree
it was beautiful it was desires to make
one wise so definitely the tenth
commandment that says i shall not covet
that's that's where it started and
in reality almost all sin begins with
the breaking of the tenth commandment
which is covetousness or selfishness and
then of course she took something that
didn't belong to her god said you can
have all of the fruit of the trees of
the garden but you're not supposed to
eat the tree in the midst of the garden
uh and of course she took and aided so
that would break the commandment that
says that i shall not steal
uh she desired she chose a god above god
so yes she broke the first commandments
she did choose a different god above god
um and then of course she gave it to a
husband and the result of which was
death
and in one sense adam and eve could
could have also broken the commandment
that says thy shall not kill because
jesus god made it clear that the day
ether of you shall surely die so when
you look at when you look at what
happened in the garden of eden it wasn't
just one commandment that was broken
it's sort of a chain reaction
and i think definitely the tenth would
be one of the most obvious and the one
that says thou shall not steal and then
of course i shall have no other gods
before me
fantastic thank you very much all right
great question thanks for your call all
right next we have uh
ricardo from fresno california he's also
asking and ask about genesis ricardo
good evening you're on the air
good evening pastors
all right so my question is in regards
to genesis 3
and so i'm just going to read it says it
says on the first chapter genesis 3
verse 1 says the serpent was more subtle
than the beast of the field
so then as i go down to 14
so
my question is really is um did the
serpent have a choice as being a medium
because when i read uh verse 14
well the curse starts with the
ringleader
and so um and it says
and it says verse 14 it says and the
lord god had said to the serpent because
thou has done this and so as you as i
read further down he speaks to the
serpent almost well in the same words he
spoke to adam and eve
so which gives me an understanding that
the serpent had
an opportunity to be the medium or not
is my question okay the medium of
of the devil sure so in other words
did the the snake have a choice in the
matter yeah uh no i don't believe the
snake had a choice you know the animal
didn't have the ability to choose um the
devil did impersonate the serpent or
maybe he possessed the serpent we do
know that
evil spirits or demons are able to
possess animals and the reason we know
that you'll remember the story where
there were two demoniacs and jesus cast
the evil spirits out of them and they
went into the pigs and the pigs went and
drowned in the sea of galilee so it is
possible for animals to be
possessed by evil spirits so
the devil possessed the snake and
apparently serpents back then must have
been dazzling creatures it must have
been beautiful
uh quite possibly they even had the
ability to fly because the you know
after
uh adam and eve sinned the curse that
came upon the serpent is from now on
you're going to go about on your belly
so um bible scholars do think that it's
possible that snakes might have even had
wings prior to that
but unfortunately yes because the devil
used a serpent from then on a serpent
becomes a symbol
of rebellion a symbol of satan and in
verse 14 where god is speaking to the
serpent
of course the serpent here is a symbol
of the devil
and whenever somebody sees the snake
there to remember
what rebellion has done
so no unfortunately the snake didn't
have a choice in the matter
but he does become a symbol of the devil
and sin
does that help you
yeah it sure does it does help a lot and
i appreciate you guys ministry and god
bless all right thanks for your call
amen thank you very much
next we have jordan from tennessee
jordan you are on the air
hi
hi thanks for calling
chris um i had a question about psalm
116 i've read it in different versions i
still can't understand what that
part is saying
uh you mentioned psalms 116
yes
was there a particular verse
um
um three
through say seven
okay well let's look at a few of them
another we have folks who are driving
and they might not have the bible there
near to them but let me read a few
verses psalm 116 verse 3 says the pains
of death surrounded me and the pangs of
sheol or other words the greys
laid hold of me i found trouble and
sorrow then i called upon the name of
the lord o lord i implore you deliver my
soul
gracious is the lord and righteous yes
our god is merciful the lord preserves
the simple
and was brought low
he saved me
return to your rest of my soul for the
for the lord has doubted bountifully
with you
and so the the question is what is what
is david speaking about here in this
verse
yeah okay well of course remember david
was being hunted by saul for a number of
years prior to him actually becoming
king and david had a number of close
calls where god preserved his life for a
while there he was living in the
wilderness he was living in a cave he
had to escape to the area controlled by
the philistines
and he had to learn three experiences to
become very dependent upon god and he
saw god protect him on many occasions
and this psalm is a psalm of
thanksgiving for
god's deliverance of david and it's of
course applicable to believers as well
but it's a it's a psalm of praise
thanking god for his deliverance so in
essence david is saying i came very
close to death where he says the pains
of death surrounded me it's as if the
grave laid hold of him but god delivered
him from that there were times when it
seemed as though david was doomed and
then the last minute god sort of opened
up the way
and he found a way of escape or he was
rescued on on many occasions so that's
really what what the psalm is about it's
a psalm of praise for the deliverance
and the mercy of god
all right well thank you okay great
thanks for calling all right thank you
next we have another caller down that
same line the same topic it says billy
from texas billy good evening you're on
the air
um i just uh was trying to ask about uh
i think it's luke 16
around
24 yeah 24. rich man and lazarus um
yeah if um if
we if we're not going to heaven or hell
until the rapture then i don't see where
this uh scripture just that's where my
question is okay great question thanks
for thanks for asking that for those who
might be listening and you're not once
again you're not familiar with luke
chapter 16 verse 19 we find an
interesting parable it's the parable
there about
the hitting of that is the rich man and
lazarus and so jesus told this parable
about a certain rich man who was living
very well and there was a beggar named
lazarus that was lying at his gate and
the rich man didn't provide anything to
help the poor man
but over time the rich man died and
lazarus died and then in the parable
lazarus goes to a place of paradise
referred to here's abraham's bosom we'll
talk about that in just a minute whereas
the rich man goes to a place of torment
or hell
and then the rich man who's in hell
looks up to lazarus who is in abraham's
bosom and says
you know it's so hot down here can you
just put a little drop of water on my
tongue
and the message comes back no there's a
great gulf fixed we can't do that but
then the rich man calls back up again
and says you know i have these other
brothers i have five brothers
and i don't want them to come to this
place of torment
so i beg of you send someone to my
father's house send lazarus to my
father's house so that he can warn them
then the message comes back while they
have moses and the prophets let them
hear them
and then he said no father abraham but
if one goes from the dead they will
repent
verse 31 but he said if they do not hear
moses and the prophets neither will they
be persuaded though one rise from the
dead now this parable
is not a description of what happens
when a person dies
the bible makes it clear that when a
person dies his next conscious thought
is the second coming of christ
and the glorious resurrection if they're
a believer but jesus is making a very
important point notice this is the only
parable pastor carlos where somebody in
the parable is actually named here we
have a parable with a name and this
person's name is lazarus and lazarus
dies and the question is asked well they
will believe if lazarus is resurrected
well the reality is that shortly after
this parable was told somebody whose
name was lazarus
did die and three days later jesus did
resurrect him and still the religious
leaders refused to acknowledge jesus as
the messiah so this was really a parable
pointing out their unbelief and their
stubbornness to acknowledge the fact
that jesus was the messiah
it was also
part of the greek mythology the greeks
had this belief that kind of filtered a
little way even into judaism at the time
that there was this place of torment and
this place of paradise and immediately
when a person died they went to one
place or the other and jesus used that
common belief to illustrate a truth and
the truth is
even if somebody is resurrected from the
dead in that case lazarus that's not
going to be enough to convince somebody
if they turn away from the word of god
that's really what the parable is all
about
okay okay
so it's just
a comparison kind of a parable just okay
yes to make the point and again it's the
the point is is quite clear there that
it's talking about somebody by the name
of lazarus who was resurrected from the
dead and the religious leaders still
refused to acknowledge jesus i think it
also points to at the end it says the
the save they're looking at the lost
that context and i think it's also
making reference to the millennium
when right before the fire comes to
consume
the those inside of the city are looking
at those on the outside and those on the
outside are looking at the inside so i
think it also ties in a little bit of
the that's right and every destiny is
set right yeah there's no changing
changing sides you know we do have a
lesson some people do have a question
about this and the subject of what
happens when a person dies we do have a
study guide that's simply called are the
dead really dead and it explores this
bible truth and many others and actually
deals with this passage of scripture
we'll be happy to send that study guide
to anyone who calls and asks the number
to call for that is 800-835-6747
and again you can just ask for the study
guide it's called are the dead really
dead and we have a magazine that you can
get through amazing fact called
deathtruth.com that also deals with the
subject who do we have next all right
next we have hannah calling from abilene
texas
hello hannah you are on the air
hi anna are you there
yes i'm here all right then your
question this evening
okay my question comes from first
timothy
um it is 5 23 where it says no longer
drink water but use a little wine for
your stomach's sake and your frequent
infirmities and i know we're not
supposed to drink alcohol and i'm just
wondering if i'm misunderstanding that
okay good question yes um
there are situations not not as you know
today it's it's a little different we do
get fresh drinking water
but as far back as the middle ages in
england and throughout europe the water
was
wasn't fresh and of course they the way
they farmed there was a lot of runoff
into the streams and the rivers it was
somewhat difficult at times to get fresh
water and you could get various
bacterial diseases from just drinking
river water
what's been referred to here is
apparently timothy was struggling with
some type of stomach ailment because it
says frequent infirmities
and the point being made is that this
was a if you like a prescription that
was given
to timothy saying this will help
your stomach condition this is not a
endorsement to drink alcohol
it was for medical use only and of
course we do know that alcohol does have
certain medicinal
uses we use alcohol today to help clean
wounds
and to help with infection and that was
really the situation that was being
addressed there it was not saying you
know timothy drink alcohol on a regular
basis because the bible tells us that
wine is a mocker strong drink is raging
whoever is deceived thereby is not wise
so this was for a specific health
situation
okay cool
thank you very much all right you're
welcome thanks for calling you know
pastor carlos we do have a book talking
about uh alcohol it's called alcohol and
the christian and deals with the subject
we'll send it to anyone who calls and
asks the number is 800-835-6747
and just ask for the book it's called
alcohol and the christian we'll be happy
to send it to you that is if you're in
north america now if you're outside of
north america we're not going to be able
to send you the book but you can go to
the amazing facts website just
amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read the book for
free right there online
who do we have next next we have jeff
from montana good evening jeff welcome
to bible answers live
i was reading the parable of the
unforgiving servant in matthew 18
and in verse 34 from the new king james
version it reads and the master was
angry and delivered him to the torturers
until he should pay all that was due him
and i recognize the way that's written
uh it's a dangling participle in the
sense that
is it the unforgiving servant is
supposed to repay the master what he
owed the master or is it supposed or is
he being the unforgiving servant
supposed to pay what was due him of his
fellow servant
and i know the latter sentiment might
not make as much sense but i was looking
at the greek word used for pay
and its epididymy which can mean to give
away or give up
or restore or yield and so i was
thinking about what unforgiveness does
to us as
we are the ones that are tortured by
unforgiveness unless we give up or yield
through forgiveness what might what we
might think is owed us
and so i wanted to your get your take on
that yeah absolutely i think you bring
up a very good point um people that
refuse to forgive others and of course
we're talking about
situation or experiences that might be
very difficult but
a person who holds on to anger
and hatred towards another it might be a
family member and they hate their family
member for years and years the reality
is that it's actually eating them up
from the inside
but if the person can get to the point
with god's help of letting that go
of saying you know i forgive them and
placing the person in god's hands
and trusting in god's in god's dealings
there is a sense of peace and a joy that
comes so in one sense yes those who
refuse to forgive they bring upon
themselves their own torture
and ultimately for those who have hurt
others there is a day of reckoning the
bible makes it clear that there is a
judgment and people will give an account
of the things that they have done
especially in hurting others a
revelation talks about jesus in
revelation chapter 22 jesus says behold
i come quickly and my reward is with me
to give to every man according to his
deeds so
there is a reward for the righteous but
there's also
results for the wicked based upon what
they have done to hurt other people but
the importance of giving each other
of course that's the commandment that
jesus gave he says how can your father
in heaven forgive you if you refuse to
forgive your fellow man we're not saying
it's always easy to forgive but by god's
grace one is to ask for that and seek
that forgiveness you know when we
understand how much god has forgiven us
it makes a little easier for us to be
able to forgive our fellow man and
that's why we need to receive that
forgiveness friends we're taking a short
break we'll come back with more bible
questions
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
amazing facts offer some of the best
christian resources for all ages we hope
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the lord
in the blueprint bible lessons
you'll uncover the history of good
versus evil and learn how this ages old
conflict makes sense of our world
and your life
get yours today by calling
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture
egyptians built pyramids to help guide
the spirits of their leaders
rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet
today ancient folklore of spirits and
apparitions have gone from mere
superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality
scientific organizations investigate
stories of hauntings and sightings
trying to prove once and for all the
existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still
no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
why do these stories persist
does it even matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself
visit ghosttruth.com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live we're just delighted that
you're joining us we want to welcome
those who are listening on radio across
the country and also those who are
joining us on the internet around the
world and also pastor carlos those who
are watching on af tv we've only been
broadcasting live on af tv for about oh
three or four weeks now so this is
exciting we want to greet those who are
watching on af tv again if you have a
bible related question all you have to
do is
call the number it's
800-463-7297 with your bible question we
have a number of folks waiting to get
their questions on the air so if you
don't get right you don't get through
right away just stay on the phone and
one of our answers will get to you well
pastor carlos who do we have uh next
next we have henry calling from the
bronx new york henry welcome you are on
the air
yes how are you
my question is uh
was cleopatra
born before the passover or after
okay
yeah let me let me give you the answer
to that um cleopatra was born a long
time after the passover because the
passover was the children of israel
leaving egypt
cleopatra wasn't born until around 51 bc
she was actually the daughter of ptolemy
the the sixth i believe
and he was one of those greek uh rulers
that was taking control of the area of
egypt and i like so cleopatra was born
in 51 around 51 bc so
you know less than 50 years before
christ yeah thanks henry who do we have
next
next we have a question from barb
barbara we're in orlando florida barbara
welcome to the program
hi hello you guys um my question is uh
revelation chapter 21
um revelation chapter 21 talks about we
will be with god for like a thousand
years
and um satan will be locked up for a
thousand years so i'm wondering um where
are like the rest of the world like the
people that believe in god like where
are they going to be will they be dead
like where exactly they're going to be
what's going to happen okay
yes
good question
all right let me give you a quick
background to revelation 20 and then we
can talk about the millennium revelation
19 ends with a picture of the second
coming of jesus jesus described remember
revelation is a symbolic book and jesus
described as coming on a white horse
with the armies of heaven that would be
the angels he's not literally coming on
a horse but a conqueror would often
ride
into battle on a horse to bring
deliverance to someone or to gain
victory over someone and so here in
revelation 19 jesus is pictured as
coming on a white horse it's a symbol of
the second coming of christ
when jesus comes
the wicked will turn to the rocks and
the mountains this is revelation chapter
6 the last verse the last couple verses
revelation 6
the wicked will turn to the rocks and
the mountains and they will say fall on
us and hide us from the face of him who
sits upon the throne from the wrath of
the lamb for the great day of his wrath
has come and who shall be able to stand
uh the bible also tells us in second
thessalonians that when the lord comes
when the second coming takes place
the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of christ coming
so these two groups when jesus comes
there are the wicked who are alive they
destroyed with the brightness of christ
coming
then you have the righteous who are
alive at the time of christ coming and
they are translated they are transformed
they receive their glorified bodies and
they are caught up to meet jesus in the
air
and you have a third group which are the
resurrected righteous ones they're also
resurrected at the second coming and
they are caught up to meet jesus in the
air then the righteous will go back to
heaven for a thousand years and
revelation talks about this one thousand
year period known as the millennium so
what's happening on earth during the
thousand years well all the wicked are
dead
the devil and his angels are here on the
earth and that's what it talks about in
revelation chapter 20 where he talks
about the devil he's bound by this chain
and he's placed in this bottomless pit
it's not talking about some deep cave
you can't
restrain a spirit being with a chain but
it's a chain of circumstances the devil
is here on the earth he is nobody to
tempt he can't go anywhere god won't let
him leave the earth so for a thousand
years the devil and his angels are here
all the righteous are in heaven the
wicked are dead then at the end of the
1000 years known as the millennium you
read about in revelation chapter 21
it talks about the new jerusalem coming
down from god out of heaven
and the new jerusalem comes to the earth
with all of the saved it's at that time
that jesus sets his foot on the mount of
olives and it opens up and forms a great
valley and the new jerusalem comes to
rest
and then all of the wicked are
resurrected so the righteous are inside
the new jerusalem the wicked are outside
the new jerusalem and we have what we
call the great white throne judgment
and at the end of that great white
throne judgment according to revelation
chapter 20 it says the wicked surround
the beloved city they surround the new
jerusalem they try to attack the new
jerusalem but then fire comes down and
devours them and the fire that destroys
the wicked destroys the devil and his
angels and purifies the earth
and then god creates a new heavens and a
new earth wearing dwells righteousness
so that's just a quick synopsis of
events that ought to take place from the
second coming of christ to the third
coming of christ that happens at the end
of the 1000 year period
so at that time will they be judge like
the wicked people yes now of course um
the decision is already made as to who's
saved and lost the time of the second
coming
so when jesus comes the righteous
they're going to be taken to heaven the
wicked they're going to be destroyed
with the brightness of christ coming
but during the 1000 years where the
saints live and reign with christ for a
thousand years
they will be participating that is the
save they'll be participating or
validating you might say the judgments
that god has already made the bible
tells us maybe carlos you can look it up
that the righteous will even judge the
angels yes
uh so during that one thousand year time
period there is a judgment that occurs
and
the righteous will even have some part
to play in the judgment of the angels
let alone the judgment of the wicked
but at the end of that thousand years
the wicked are resurrected where they
get a chance to actually see the
evidence and they could ask the question
why am i not in the city god's going to
make it very clear and at the end of
that judgment the bible says every knee
shall bow every tongue will confess even
the devil that jesus is lord but it's
not a confession out of guilt or sorrow
for sin it's just an acknowledgement of
the evidence because no sooner do they
say that then they try to destroy the
new jerusalem
yeah that verse is first corinthians
chapter six verse three first
corinthians chapter six verse three that
says well do you have it there can you
read it for us
well i have it in spanish but i read it
it says yes will you not know that we
shall also judge the angels how much
more then shall we judge the things of
this life all right very good
translation there pastor call us
does that help barbara
yes thank you very much all right you're
welcome thank you thank you you know we
do have a study guide that talks about
the 1 000 year period it's called a
thousand years of peace and if you'd
like to learn more about that we'll be
happy to send it to you the number to
call is 800 8356
and you can ask for the study guide it's
called a thousand years of peace who do
we have next next we have malaura from
wyoming good evening one hour welcome
welcome to the bible answers live
hi
laura malora laura thank you for calling
yeah um
i
in the last year i have made a lifestyle
change and i have become vegan and i
have added exercise
and i have added
um i have been studying my bible every
day for gosh at least 18 months now i
have done everything that everybody has
suggested i do
but i still
suffer
continually with depression some days
it's just all i can do to get out of bed
i don't know what i'm doing wrong
i really don't so if you could just tell
me please
i lost over 70 pounds i mean i
you know i've worked really hard
yes and you know
malaria i can understand um
i've worked with folks and had church
members and even folks close to me that
have struggled with depression and
you know depression is one of those
things that
when you're feeling depressed it's easy
to blame yourself and say you know i
must be a bad person there must be
something that i'm doing wrong
i think we need to recognize that
depression there's a number of causes
one could be somebody goes through a
dramatic experience it could be the
result of a loss of a family member
it could just be a genetic disposition
it could be a chemical imbalance there
are many different reasons for
depression one could be spiritual but
that's not always the case we even have
examples in the bible of faithful men
and women who suffer depression you read
some of the psalms where david was very
depressed and he said oh i wish i could
die
job went through a terrible time of
depression as a result of the trials
that came to him so just because the
person is facing or experiencing
depression it doesn't mean that god
doesn't love them or that they're a
great sinner or they have turned away
from god
but i think we live in a world where
there is sin
and some of the consequences of sin that
we do have is suffering and pain and
sorrow which can be depression so the
first thing i want to tell you is
don't don't be reluctant do everything
you're doing which sounds like you are
you're spending time in prayer you're
reading your bible you you're living
healthfully you're eating well you're
trying to get your exercise but
don't be reluctant to search
for and find a medical help as well
there are things that can be done to
help a person through
difficult bouts of depression
some people just have mild depression
others might go into very severe
depression and they need
they need some medical
help to get them back whether that's a
medication
or maybe some type of a treatment so i
would encourage you explore all of those
options but despite the depression the
good news is god loves you and he's able
to help you never give up keep praying
keep seeking for help and then utilize
all the resources that god has made
available to us
and realize that depression is an
illness just like any other illness it
can
can be and it can have real physical
results so take advantage of any medical
help that you can get to try and relieve
that depression
and keep keep it a burden of prayer as i
know it's a difficult thing to go
through
you know pastor carlos it's
i think part of the reason we have those
examples in the bible of people who have
suffered depression is to help us
because everybody goes through some time
of difficulty some more than others and
there could be family relations could be
genetic for some folks but just because
we're depressed it doesn't mean god
loves us less or that we're a great
sinner because some very godly men and
women in the bible suffer depression i
think of elijah
the great man of god the prophet of god
after mount carmel he got so depressed
he said lord just let me die
so yes but of course god sustained him
and brought him through so keep holding
on to god keep trusting him do
everything you can
look for medical help where needed but
ultimately god is the great physician so
hold on to him and keep trusting him i i
just want to tell malara that i used to
suffer from depression too
and uh there's one bible verse that
really helped me a lot it's isaiah 26 3
says you will keep him in perfect peace
whose mind is stayed on you because he
trusts in you trust in the lord forever
for in the jaw the lord has everlasting
strength so take these bible promises
and write them around the house around
your room and every time you feel
depressed every time you feel like you
don't want to
continue or you feel overwhelmed look at
those promises and hold on to them pray
to god
and and and and ask him for victory over
that and we know that that that the lord
wants to give us a complete victory
that's right and never give up keep
trusting the lord remember the promise
is that when jesus comes these mortal
bodies will receive immortality and we
won't be struggling with the same things
that we have here in these in these uh
mortal bodies that we have now amen so
we'll keep you in prayer malaria
who do we have next next we have lisa
from oklahoma good evening lisa you're
on the air
hello can you hear me yes we can
okay hi um
so my question
is um
looking at
abraham's example
of when god told him to take his son and
sacrifice his son
how did he know
that that was god's voice and that it
wasn't a deception
because i mean something like that is
crazy and if something like that
happened now he'd be put in jail for it
but i mean
you know you know what i'm saying he had
to have some reassurance that
this was something that was from god and
not
yes his crazy mind or yes absolutely
well several things first of all is um
remember this test didn't come to
abraham until he was
you know 120 years old so he had walked
with the lord for many years
and god spoke to him even to leave his
home in ur and go to the promised land
and there were many occasions where god
communicated with abraham directly
abraham had a very special relationship
with god
so when god told abraham to take his son
isaac and to offer him as a sacrifice it
was not just a impression that he had it
wasn't just a thought that flashed into
his mind it was very evident that this
was god speaking to him
it was clear abraham knew
and i'm sure when abraham received this
message from god that he was to
sacrifice his son i'm sure abraham spent
earnest hours in prayer you can only
imagine
how abraham must have prayed and prayed
and said lord please are you sure is
this is this really what you want me to
do and he trusted god to know that if he
was misled god would reveal that to him
and so until god would direct him
elsewhere he was going to be faithful
and keep following what god had told him
to do and of course throughout the whole
experience he still believed that isaac
was to be resurrected he believed that
even if he did sacrifice his son he
would be resurrected from the dead
because he claimed the promise of god
so it wasn't presumption on abraham's
part because he was always looking for
a different way that god might direct
but he was saying lord until you direct
me otherwise i'm going to faithfully
follow your instruction and i think
pastor carlos in the same way if if god
is asking us to do something and we are
sincere and we seek to know god's will
we can trust that if we are being misled
and we are wanting to do what's right
god will reveal that to us he'll make it
clear to us and say no no that's that's
not what i want you to do you're going
down the wrong path amen you'll make
that very clear and that's kind of what
abraham i think was looking for in that
situation as well amen does that uh help
lisa
yeah yeah that makes sense
all right very good well thanks for your
call
all right who do we have next next we
have ali calling from newark new jersey
good afternoon good evening ali you are
on the air
pastor ross hey pastor carlos um thanks
for taking my call
my can you hear me yes we can hear you
okay okay okay um my question is how can
we walk in a close fellowship with god
and jesus like enoch
abraham and noah and all the other men
of faith did and what does that look
like on a day-to-day
on a day-to-day basis
okay
question yes practically i think it
begins in the morning you know the very
moment you awake in the morning the
first thing to do is to start your day
by communing with god
uh one of the things i do the first
thought that comes to my head when i
wake up in the morning is i want to
thank the lord for another day of life
but i want to surrender my life to him
and i say lord today my life is your
life i want to do those things that you
want me to do
i surrender my heart i surrender my mind
i surrender my entire being
and then we need to spend time communing
with god spend time in his words spend
time in prayer
and then throughout the day we want to
keep that open communion with god that
connection where
we don't just think of god in the
morning and maybe for a little bit in
the evening before we go to bed but
throughout the day we're communing with
god and that's what it means to walk
with god it means to communicate with
god to commune with god throughout the
day
you know sometimes the holy spirit will
even convict us and say man you're
getting so busy and all these other
things that you haven't actually
you haven't communicated with me you
haven't prayed you haven't thought of of
me but if we're earnestly seeking to
know god and to be in harmony with him
god will guide us into a deeper
experience this doesn't happen overnight
remember enoch was 300 plus years before
he has translated
noah lived a long age abraham was a
faithful follower of god and so we can
grow we can develop
this closer union with god and that's
the goal as the christian is to come as
close to god as we can
and i think also pass across just
recognizing the presence of god
sometimes we forget that god is here
jesus said i'll never leave you nor
forsake you the holy spirit is with us
and and recognizing that that god knows
us he's concerned about us he wants to
guide us in the big things in life and
the little things in life and
recognizing that god is with us
amen
all right ali thanks for your call hope
that helps who do we have next
next we have bobby from college place
washington
hi bobby welcome to the program
well pastor um
john and pastor carlos yes that's us
uh my question is regarding um
genesis 2 7 where it talks about
um
god breathing into man's nostrils and
man becoming a living soul
but then sometimes people tell me
no that's not right kind of thing
and they
refer me to first thessalonians 5 23
where it talks about
your whole spirit soul and body being
preserved um so is there some kind of
contradiction there
well um
the word soul in the bible is used in
different ways um when you're reading in
genesis and it says god breathed into
adam the breath of life and adam became
a living soul other translations new
king james is a living being
so the word soul can can refer to a
living being an individual
but there is also that essence of
consciousness that we have our character
our personality
sometimes in scripture that's referred
to as spirit or or soul
um sort of the inner part our our
thoughts our feelings
uh and it's used interchangeably just
like the word spirit and breath is used
interchangeably in scripture we even
have examples of animal life referred to
in the bible as every every living soul
that was in the sea died it's talking
about the fish or every soul in the land
died during the time of the flood so the
word soul has different meanings so yes
it does mean just like the word spirit
it can mean our entire being
it talks about so many souls
that may be perished or so many souls
that we need to battle or so many souls
in a nation or an army but the word soul
can also refer to
a person's consciousness or their
character or personality so you got to
look at the context of the verse
okay
but again that we're not saying that the
soul is immortal and i guess that's the
point of dispute that some people have
some people believe that the soul cannot
die now that's not biblical
the bible makes it clear that adam
became a living soul when you had the
breath of life combined with the body
that's that's when we have a living
being so the bible doesn't speak of an
immortal soul
and once the the breath goes by by then
there is no longer a soul correct yep at
least in that sense of being
being a living being
all right well thank you thank you bobby
appreciate your call i think we have
time for a few more calls pastor carlos
who do we do next all right let's go
with samuel from new york city samuel
you're on the air
hey hello
carlos hello pastor ross how you doing
you're doing well
so uh before i ask my question i just
want to fill in a little background i'm
just asking this question because a few
years ago i just got
betrayed by the person that i love and
just
after that i just got a turning point
where i just i was a christian i was
going to church and doing all the
rituals i kind of didn't notice god like
i didn't talk about god or read the
bible or barely pray but after that i
just got turned in front just throwing
myself in and just think about him on a
daily basis and now i'm reading the
bible from beginning to end and kind of
going through it
but
recently ever since i got that turning
point just been falling through this
just a single scene where um the person
that i love and just being funny on loss
of scene where i just keep falling i
just keep
falling into my knees begging for
forgiveness but i think it's just i keep
just doing it and doing it and doing it
and of course i got the memory of that
person on hebrews 10 that says if we
willingly keep sinning then there's no
forgiving venezuela
and
of course i know the interpretation of
that birth which is if somebody goes out
of their way and just a fool leaving a
full line of sin i know the
interpretation but i also know the
person says um
it's better to be married than burned
with passion so my question really is
my question really is it listen uh i
just died tomorrow but i just recognized
guy and double him and i read the bible
and pray well i just keep falling into
this single scene they think i will deny
me the entrance to the kingdom okay
um so the question then if i'm
understanding correctly samuel is what
do we do if we're a believer and we find
ourselves struggling with a particular
sin and we keep stumbling over and over
again
does this verse in hebrews 10 26 apply
which says for if we sin willfully after
we receive a knowledge of the truth
there is no longer a sacrifice for sins
well you know if that was the criteria i
think all of us would be in trouble
because i don't know of one christian
that has not stumbled over the same sin
multiple times whether it be gossip or
whether it be overeating or whatever it
might be
the good news is that god is able to
save he's able to save to the uttermost
this verse is talking about an open
high-handed rebellion against god that's
when a person gets to the point where
they don't ask for forgiveness where
they begin to make excuses for sin
excusing sin in their life or saying
that it's not really sin or that it
doesn't matter
that's a dangerous thing
but if we recognize that what we are
doing or what we have done is wrong and
it's a violation of god's commandments
and we sincerely ask for forgiveness the
bible promises us that if we confess our
sins he's faithful and just to forgive
us and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness we also need to
recognize that not only does god want to
forgive us but he wants to empower us he
wants to enable us to live a victorious
christian life
how do we gain the victory over sin we
have to claim the promises found in the
bible that's how jesus overcame sin and
that's the example that he has set for
us
jesus said man shall not live by bread
alone but by every word that proceeds
out of the mouth of god
when we face temptation the thing we
must do right away
before that temptation becomes
overwhelming we need to turn to the lord
pray right then and there and say lord
please help me give me the victory just
like peter when he began to sink in the
water and all he could do is lift up his
hand and say lord save me sometimes
that's all we can do is say lord please
save me and then start quoting promises
from the bible
you know i don't know of anyone that's
able to sin while they're quoting bible
promises
and they're on their knees praying
asking for deliverance god will provide
that strength it's when we don't take
advantage of the power that god wants to
give us
that we stumble and fall into sin you
know we have a book it's called tips for
resisting temptation and gives us
step-by-step guide on how we can live a
victorious christian life how we can
overcome those those besetting sins
whatever they might be and each person
it's a little different if you'd like to
receive that book for anyone wanting to
live a victorious christian life the
number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can just ask for the book it's
called tips for resisting temptation
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
here in north america if you're outside
of north america you can read the book
for free by going to the amazing facts
website
now for those who are listening on the
radio some of you will be tuning off
those on satellite but for those who are
listening online or at amazing facts tv
stay tuned we have a special bonus
question that is coming right up
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back to our
special bonus feature of bible answers
live something new that we're doing in
the next few minutes we're going to be
taking some of the questions that folks
have emailed to us if you have a bible
question that you'd like to have us
answer on the air that you'd like to
email instead of calling in we have an
email address and pastor carlos you've
got it right there what's that email
address it's b bal questions
amazingfacts.org
b-a-l as in bible answers live
bal questions at amazingfacts.org
all right excellent so if you have a
bible question be sure to email that to
us
if that's going to be better than
calling it well pastor carlos who do we
have for tonight we have uh two
questions here the first one is from
derek brown is everybody called to be a
minister or to go into ministry is
everyone called to be a minister no not
everyone is called to be a minister
because we know that there are different
gifts of the spirit so god has given
some to be teachers and preachers and
evangelists some administrative skills
some to be helpers and helping with
different areas or caring for others
some have the gift of languages so each
person has a different gift but are we
all to be sharers of
the love of christ absolutely so in one
sense we ought to be missionaries not
all ministers meaning that we pastors
but we should all be looking for
opportunities to share the love of jesus
and especially with those who have never
experienced the love of christ or who
are not christians now there might be a
family member a neighbor maybe a
colleague so yes all of us have a part
to do in trying to share the good news
of salvation with others amen the next
question is from james from
massachusetts he says i heard in heaven
we will still grow every million years
and my question is will we ever get old
in heaven or will we ever get old in
heaven well there is probably an age a
perfect age whatever that might be
that we think of here on earth i don't
know maybe it's 30 27 5 40 27 whatever
it might be
that perfect age for those who are under
that perfect age whatever that might be
there will be some growth in heaven but
we ultimately will be what god has
purposed for us to be throughout all
eternity we know in heaven children will
grow up because the bible does speak of
children being in heaven but they will
grow up and eventually it's kind of a
sad thought even though there won't be
sadness in heaven but the children will
grow up and you won't you won't get old
in the sense of what old is here
of course we have all eternity to get to
know christ even more and those who are
saved and be in the earth made new so
thank you friends for your calls and the
emails that you sent again we want to
remind you that bible answers live is
on the air because of your support so
thank you for your faithful giving to
amazing facts to help keep bible answers
on the air we look forward to meeting
with you again next week until then god
bless
[Music]
you